[Music]
well you know this weekend Angelina
Jolie took two of her kids on a little
road trip it was no hiding from the
public as they get a huge festival in
Southern California shades on big smile
on her face
those black leather pants and moto boots
totally remind us of kick butt Tomb
Raider Angie but her favorite is that
giant $12 turkey leg Angelina was seen
eating saturday was mom's day out for
Angelina the star was accompanied by two
bodyguards as she took ten year old
daughter Shiloh dressed in camo shorts
and a hat and eight-year-old hoodie
wearing son Knox for two our visit to
the Renaissance Fair and eyewitness
tells us Angelina and the kids spent
some time in a knife shop looking at
knives
now here's major proof that Brangelina
is putting family first today we have
learned Angelina dropped around 25
million dollars and is currently in
escrow on this mansion located less than
two miles from Brad's Lowe's felis home
a source tells us Angelina wants the six
kids to be closer to Brad and this way
they can see both parents easily the 2.1
Acre home is the former Cecil B DeMille
estate it has six bedrooms and ten
bathrooms a pool and a guest house as
for Brad's new light sober after his
tell lgq style interview we're learning
new details on how the 53 year old quit
alcohol a source tells us quote he went
through counseling not rehab a separate
source adds Pitts sought counseling for
his drinking by attending meetings at a
discreet location in LA Pitts has worked
very hard to get his kids back and the
whole family is in a much better place
while the family will be pulled further
apart this fall though because Angelina
is set to teach a master's course at the
prestigious London School of Economics
as a visiting professor
[Music]
you